I'm sitting here with Jacques one of our
lead front-end web developers hi hi so I
was talking with nick about
re-architecting a little bit you know
like you've got some code it's not
necessarily up to snuff and you know you
just move things around a little bit to
get it up to snuff right so what if I
were to give you a piece of code that's
like that but worse you could sort of
still tease parts of it you know around
and sort of get into the modules or the
separations that you're interested in
and then replace those pieces as as you
work on them so if there if the codes
not stuff that you want to keep around
separating it out means that you get to
burn little pieces of it at a time and
replace them and upgrade them and make
them make them better that makes sense
so what if i give you some code that's
even worse than that like let's just say
big mess of spaghetti code if you can't
tease it apart or if there aren't good
ideas that you'd like to keep just burn
it to the ground just start just take it
all the way and rebuild that
functionality they just like that Wow
okay um so I guess you're giving me
permission to burn horrible spaghetti
code to the ground absolutely you will
thank yourself in the future what if
it's worse than that um nuke it from
space have a friend delete it for you
haha don't even don't even look at it no
now just okay so wonderful now you have
permission to delete horrible awful
spaghetti code from your projects so you
you actually have done this yeah oh have
you ever nuked something from space
between Nick and I we we have done that
absolutely like hey could you get rid of
all of that I'll I'll replace it oh boy
fantastic or horrifying or terrible yeah
we're a bit of both awesome well thanks
for sitting with me and talking about
this absolutely